honecker saute le mur pour faire ami ami
avec son frère ennemi ce n'est pas tout
à fait ça mais presque puisque le numéro
un du parti communiste est allemand
commence aujourd'hui une visite
officielle de cinq jours en allemagne
fédérale visite historique la première
du genre après quarante années de
brouille et parfois de haine
philippe rochot a suivi pour nous son
arrivée
quarante ans après erich honecker pose
le pied pour la première fois sur ce
territoire qui est aujourd'hui
l'allemagne de l'ouest
tous les honneurs dus à un chef d'état
lui ont été réservés même si
officiellement ce voyage de cinq jours
est une visite de travail au necker
artisan de la construction du mur de
berlin est aujourd'hui accueillis par
des familles est-allemande établi à bonn
et par les honneurs militaires
voilà six ans qu'on l'attendait au
necker avait d'abord été invité par le
chancelier schmidt en 80 puis par le
chancelier kohl
à son arrivée au pouvoir aujourd'hui les
drapeaux des deux allemagnes flottent
dans le ciel de la capitale fédérale et
l'hymne nationale de la république
démocratique allemande résonne pour la
première fois devant la chancellerie
fédérale
dès son arrivée erich honecker à parler
de désarmement
il n'oublie pas que le déclic qui permet
son voyage c'est le feu vert de
l'allemagne fédérale à l'option double
zéro mais sa visite marque aussi
l'amélioration des échanges entre les
deux allemagnes au necker a fait libérer
2000 prisonniers politiques et autorise
cette année deux millions de citoyens
est-allemands à venir en allemagne
fédérale
on ne parlera pas de la réunification
allemande mais l'idée reste dans l'air
amélioration des relations entre les
deux états allemands contribuer à
l'amélioration du climat est veste et
c'est dans un climat seulement qu'une
lointaine ray cohabitation s'il voulait
entre deux états allemands dont
l'ensemble de l'allemagne 10 comme un
rappel l'allemagne c'est le plan
culturel sera possible la volonté de
rapprochement entre les deux allemagnes
se manifeste pourtant à nouveau hier
soir à berlin est un millier de jeunes
ont demandé que les échanges avec
l'allemagne fédérale se développe encore
et que le mur disparaissent